bon certains pays du monde défendre
l'environnement c'est risquer sa vie
selon le rapport annuel de los angels
obel witness en 2010 9 212 activistes
ont été tués
40% des victimes étaient des
représentants de populations autochtones
en effet de nombreux exploitants
illégaux cible des territoires indigènes
pour y implanter leurs activités une
spoliation qui pousse les peuples
autochtones à quitter leurs terres ou à
se battre pour les défendre des
exactions qui se multiplient et encore
largement sous-estimée selon les ong
le nombre réel est probablement bien
plus élevé car beaucoup de cas ne sont
pas répertoriés et font rarement l'objet
d' enquête est bien plus de personnes
ont été attaquées emprisonnés ou ont été
visés par des campagnes de dénigrement à
cause de leur travail
l'amérique latine reste la zone la plus
dangereuse puisque le continent
comptabilise plus des deux tiers des
meurtres d'activistes écologie compte
2019 et tout particulièrement en
colombie où 64 victimes ont été
comptabilisés par global witness l'année
dernière francia marquez a échappé à un
attentat après avoir fait campagne pour
la préservation des cours d'eau contre
des exploitations minières
pour la militante des droits humains et
de l'environnement est très activiste
représente un grand danger en colombie
un défenseur de l'environnement
représente une menace aujourd'hui en
colombie mais c'est le cas partout dans
le monde car c'est un combat entre deux
projets de vie de projet politique pas
d'armes mais nous avons nos voix
continuer à défendre le futur de notre
pays ont continué à défendre le futur de
l'humanité
l'asie et en particulier les philippines
concentré gars le monde de nombreuses
violences notamment liées à la
résistance opposée aux excès de
l'industrie agro alimentaire
quarante trois activistes ont ainsi été
assassinés dans l'archipel d'asie du
d'est une violence alimentée par la
corruption et l'inaction des états
vis-à-vis des acteurs économiques
impliqués selon les ong global witness
certains gouvernement use même de
stratégie d'intimidation pour réduire au
silence les défenseurs de
l'environnement